benimon if the wall hadn't fallen we'd
never met Gloria ya zo nevsky is from
western Germany Hendrik khobor from
eastern Germany they lived together in
the capital Berlin and take walks along
the border strip that was once a no
man's land in the middle of the
fortification surrounding what was West
Berlin more than 25 years ago it's a
significant place for them Hannity cut
me goes downwards could hike pan Rick
showed it to me back then that was just
after we've gotten together and we took
a walk here about all that for this did
you sister died hunter among bias when
you think about what might have happened
here what was done to people what people
might have felt who stood in front of it
it makes you think because this toilet
to this I think it's amazing that I can
just go over to the other side I think
if things had gone differently i'd have
to stop here and would only learn about
everything on the other side from TV and
radio and I'd feel like a captive
because I love freedom anguish bad food
and guns comedy have hired Steven
aménagement Hendrik was born in what was
East Berlin in 1989 shortly before the
Wall fell Gloria was born in oldenburg
in western Germany to polish parents
both love music three years ago they met
at a music festival and fell in love now
they have two children Linda and Paulina
the couple isn't married like most of
the generation born in 1989 and 90
only eleven percent have tied the knot
many don't want to tie themselves down
too soon itself helium a lot of people
give up much too early in a relationship
they're dissatisfied with their partners
and tell themselves if they break up
they'll find someone else who's a better
fit or who's even more perfect but I
don't believe that actually happens so
we keep this garnish the young parents
often face challenges Gloria is studying
to be an illustrator after their first
daughter was born Hendrik stayed home at
first to take care of the baby so Gloria
could continue her education even for
their generation that's still unusual
now with their second child Gloria has
taken parenting leave after that she
plans to finish her degree he's good no
need for any guns I couldn't imagine
just staying at home all the time that's
not my world at all I also need time
where I can just draw people also need
to have a sense of achievement also I
need to see that besides being a mother
I can also do other things Hendrix
started out studying to become a social
education worker and is now training to
teach children with disabilities that
puts him in the 35 percentile of his
generation committed to political or
social causes they come to him indeed I
think about yeah I go there and I see
that I'm needed and working in special
education sometimes I get a smile from
kids who have very serious disabilities
hobbies do a few children who have to
wear diapers who can't do much for
themselves you can you call move us
cutting above it but when they do smile
all that hard work is worth it as in
this page
this V fixed if what's most important to
me in life is the freedom to live with
my family and friends on mine find Liam
sukin luckily sad to be happy I need my
family my friends my music and my art my
name Zeke on my knuckles the fact that
the couple or parent in their mid-20s
isn't at all typical of their generation
whether from east or west even before
reunification on average West German
women had their first child at about the
age of 27 in the former East Germany
first-time mothers were about four years
younger since then the two parts of the
country have converged and the average
age for first-time birth has risen
museum said women we see my parents as
role models hopefully by our mid 40s the
kids will be out of the house and we can
do what we want and then we'll be
professionally active again and we can
decide to take a year's sabbatical and
travel the world and won't have to worry
kind of long for my house I did hi the
grandparents support the young family as
best they can Hendrick and glorious
still notice small differences between
the former East and West in their
generation they think their children
will be the first without an awareness
of German division it's not so evident
in our generation people have formed
their own opinions our children have the
chance to grow up as a truly independent
generation of course we are still
influenced by division and think about
it but they can grow up as unified
German so to speak what they make of
that remains to be seen you know what
smocking van lier speed
you